you just started a war how did this tom  holland rivalry begin well I was on set  and he just wouldn't stop talking and I  was like yo man just go your baby your  babysitters over there tell your baby  started to get you a juice box and you  know he's just the kids a problem all  right the kids a problem and we're  dealing with him over at Marvel  accordingly because he's a problem  she stayed close to the ground  spider-man you too we get a Comedy  Central Roast out of this hopefully I  don't know because you when you do a  roast you do things that aren't true  this is real life this is real life I  mean he took my car I got my car back  there were no tires he wrecked my car  the kids a problem yeah  [Music]